[موسيقى]
التوتر العلاقه بين رونالدو ووكيل اعماله
السرطان يبعدوا فيالا عن منتخبه ايطاليا
ومودريتش ينتقدوا حكم مباراه الارجنتين
هذه الاخبار وغيرها تتابعون على العربيه
اهلا بكم
[موسيقى]
يبدو ان تبيعات اقصاء البرتغال من كاس
العالم بدات بظهور في حياه رونالدو بعد ما
اكدت تقارير اعلاميه توتر العلاقه بينه
وبين وكيل اعماله
التوتر العلاقه بينهما سببه ان رونالدو لم
يجد بعد فريقا ينتقل اليه بعد فسخ عقده
بالتراضي مع يونايتد
وبعد خمس سنوات من تشخيص اصابته بمرض
السرطان ابتعد جنبك عن الطاقم الفني
للمنتخب الايطاليه المرضي اليه مجددا وقال
فياري بانه وبعد شعوره بالالام تواصل مع
الفريق الطبي الخاص به واتفقوا على
ابتعاده عن العام الحاليا واللعب فياري
دور المهمه في فوز الازوري بلقب بطوله
اوروبا الماضيه مع المدرب مانشستر
سيتي
الارجنتين وهو القرار الذي اثار الكثير من
الجدل بسبب موقف الحارس امام المهاجم
الارجنتيني جوليان باريس
لاعبوا البرازيل لا يزنون تحت صدمه
الاقصاء ومنهم ريتشارليسون مهاجم توتنهام
الانجليزي
بالاضافه الى نيمار و رونالدو
[موسيقى]